هروب من واقع مر ام هجره جماعيه بين هاتين
يتارجح واقع الاطباء الصعب في تونس
فالمشافتئن وتخلو من كوادرها
حسب الارقام لمددنا بهم العماده اكثر من
900 طبيب شاب وحتى شبان حتى لاكبر في
العمر واكثر خبره اللي يغادروا البلاد
التونسيه هديه معناها مصدر قلق بالنسبه
لنا احنا علاج خطر التوازنات معناها في
عدد الاطباء
محاوله طبيبه الانتحار لرفض اجازه مرضيه
نصح بها طبيبه النفسي كشفت الكثير عن
معاناه اطباء تونس واعادت الجدل حول ظروف
عملهم الصعبه
وساعات عملهم الطويله
وفي اطار اخر عزاء طبيب رفض الكشف عن اسمه
عزا سبب هجره الاطباء الى تدني رواتبهم
مقارنه بما يتقاضاؤه في بلدان اوروبيه او
خليجيه واقع يسرع نبضات المخاوف من نقص
الكوادر الطبيه
ويدقون قوس خطر ينذر بنزيف قد يؤدي
لانهيار قطاع الصحه في البلاد
محمد فروانه العربيه